rewrite the expression 5 times 9 minus 4
that's in parentheses using the
distributive law of multiplication over
subtraction then simplify so if we let
me just rewrite it so this is going to
be 5 times 9 minus 4 9 9 minus 4 9 minus
4 just like that now if we want to use
the distributive property but you don't
have to you could just evaluate 9 minus
4 and then multiply that times 5 but if
you want to use the distributive
property you distribute the 5 you
multiply the 5 times the 9 and the 4 so
you end up with 5 times 9 5 times 9
minus minus 5 times 4 minus 5 times 4
notice we distributed the 5 we
multiplied it times both the 9 and the 4
and in the first distributive property
video we gave you an idea of why you
have to distribute the 5 why it makes
sense why you don't just multiply it by
the 9 we're going to verify that it
gives us the same answer as if we just
evaluated the 9 minus 4 first but anyway
what are these things so 5 times 9 that
is 45 so you have 45 minus what's 5
times 4 well that's 20 45 minus 20 and
that is equal to well that's equal to 25
so this is using the distributive
property right here if we didn't want to
use the distributive property if we just
wanted to evaluate within the
parentheses first we would have gotten
let's go in this direction
5 times what's 9 minus 4 9 minus 4 9
minus 4 is 5 let me do that in a
different color 5 times 9 minus 4 so
it's 5 times 5 5 times 5 is just 25 so
we get the same answer either way this
is using the distributive law of
multiplication over subtraction usually
just referred to as the distributive
property this is evaluating the inside
of the parentheses first and then
multiplying by 5